teachers are on strike again this
morning across Oklahoma to protest low
wages and cuts in school funding an
estimated 36 thousand teachers flooded
the State Capitol in Oklahoma City
yesterday teachers also rallied in
Kentucky's Capitol to oppose legislation
there that they say would damage their
pension system and unrest now threatens
to grow in Arizona where teachers have
demanded higher pay for weeks now Omar
Villafranca is in Oklahoma City with the
latest on this story
Omar good morning good morning thousands
of teachers are expected to rally again
here at the State Capitol and they are
frustrated after years of cuts to
education funding and now the teachers
are saying very loudly no more they
arrived by the busload teachers across
Oklahoma are demanding better
investments in schools students and
themselves Oklahoma needs to step up
while many of the state's largest school
districts were closed
some students showed up outside the
Capitol for actual classes led by their
teachers high school sophomore hope
Davis says she's had to resort to taking
many of her classes online our teacher
resigned to mid semester so I switched
online classes do you feel you're
getting a better education online than
in Oklahoma classroom last week Oklahoma
governor mary Fallon signed a bill that
included a roughly $6,000 pay raise for
teachers and an additional fifty million
dollars in education funding many
demonstrators say that's not enough
after demanding a $10,000 raise for
teachers and an added two hundred
million dollars over three years in
educational funding the legislators have
pushed the envelope pretty far this year
there still will be next year and I
think we continue having that discussion
a discussion National Education
Association president Lillie
Eccleston Garcia says needs to happen
now
been giving everything they got the
legislature can't keep exploiting and
taking advantage of the people who love
their students by expecting them to pick
up the difference the head of the
Oklahoma teachers union says that these
rallies will continue until lawmakers
increase funding and one teacher told me
they are taking notes on the votes and
plan to take their frustration to the
polls in November John okay Omar thanks
so much